hey 42 here women make 25% of the films
and around compared to 4% in the u.s.
welcome to RIF by 2025 there will be
more English speakers in China than in
the rest of the world put together it
takes 3,000 cows to supply the NFL with
enough lever for a year's supply of
footballs a ball of glass will bounce
higher than a ball of rubber and a ball
of solid steel will bounce higher than
one made entirely of glass gram for gram
hamburgers cost more than new cars the
sentence the quick brown fox jumped over
the lazy dog uses every letter in the
alphabet for this reason it is often
used to showcase typefaces a full moon
is nine times brighter than a half moon
dart boards are made out of horse hairs
Beethoven will dip his head in cold
water before he composed to stimulate
his mind a jiffy is an actual unit of
time it's 100 of a second Russia didn't
consider beer to be an alcoholic
beverage until 2011 it was previously
classified as a soft drink monks that
begin on a Sunday will always have a
Friday the 13 the Titanic had a sister
ship called the Olympic and it provided
25 years of good service during his
lifetime an oyster changes its sexes for
male to female and back again several
time the average secretaries left hand
does 56% of the typing despite China
having a population of 1.4 billion there
are only about 200 different surnames in
China cotton candy was invented by a
dentist thanks for the view subscribe
for more 42
you